Bad Bunny is a trap
rapper who is making waves
in the Latin music world.
His debut album, "X 100PRE,"
scored the No. 1 spot
on the Top Latin Albums chart this year.
But it's probably not the
first time you've seen him.
He's worked with Cardi B on "I Like It"
and "Mia" with Drake.
And he just dropped his
new song, "Callaita."
But Bad Bunny's appeal extends beyond
these star-studded music collaborations.
He's been instrumental
in bringing Latin trap
to mainstream American audiences
while rapping mostly in Spanish.
Bad Bunny originally posted his music
on SoundCloud independently
but was quickly noticed and
signed on to a record label.
Since then, he's been a
consistent heavy hitter
on the Hot Latin Songs chart,
with 46 tracks, and seven on the Hot 100.
Along with his own singles, he's teamed up
with other Hispanic and Latino top artists
to create Billboard hits,
such as "Sensualidad" with
J Balvin and Prince Royce,
and a remix of "Te Bote"
with Ozuna and Nicky Jam.
In 2018, he collaborated
with Cardi B and J Balvin
for "I Like It,"
making it Bad Bunny's first No. 1 single
on the US Billboards.
It was followed with another collaboration
with Drake for "Mia," and
Jennifer Lopez for "Te Guste,"
garnering him even more fans in the US
and around the world.
This leads up to his
debut album, "X 100PRE,"
which, unsurprisingly,
skyrocketed to the No. 1 spot
on the Top Latin Albums chart.
With his rhythmic cadence and slow slurs,
Bad Bunny has a unique
sound that is unlike
anything else on the Latin music scene.
This is largely due to his willingness
to cross music genres,
ranging from Latin trap,
reggaeton, and pop.
In an interview with Billboard, he credits
his unique music style to his parents
and home country of Puerto Rico.
When he was little, he listened to salsa,
merengue, and pop ballads.
At the same time, he was singing
to reggaeton and hip hop.
Bad Bunny's rise to fame isn't only
attributed to his music,
but to his unshakeable sense of self.
He has a distinct style,
with his painted nails
and bright patterns, which have made him
a fashion inspiration.
And you're likely to spot him
with a pair of trendy shades.
In a music culture that often champions
traditional masculinity, Bad
Bunny is a breath of fresh air
that redefines gender norms
and societal expectations.
Through his music and clothing choices,
he preaches messages of
self-love and respect for others.
In the music video for "Caro,"
there are several gender-bending moments,
and even a scene featuring
an inclusive fashion show,
with models of varying ages,
abilities, races, and sizes.
In another music video for "Solo De Mi,"
he tackles the issue of
domestic violence against women.
With just three years
in the music industry
under his belt, Bad Bunny
has become one of the most
recognizable faces of Latin trap
while also helping bring
Latin music to the mainstream.
In 2018, Bad Bunny was YouTube's
third-most-viewed artist,
with 7 billion views.
Now, Bad Bunny is headlining
his own international tour
and selling out venues across the world.
He sold out his homecoming concerts
in Puerto Rico within hours,
which led to adding a third day.
In addition, J Balvin has teased
an upcoming collaborative album.
Whatever the next album may be,
we can't wait to see more from Bad Bunny.